Lake Constance in southern Germany the
Haitian restaurant and hotel overlooks
the western shore across from
Switzerland it's been a family-owned
establishment for seven generations
since 1821
for Euro Maxon the cart chef Marcos
Marek is preparing veal filet with
asparagus and nettle noodles he picks
the nettles in the hotel garden with
gloves on
that's because raw nettles sting if you
touch them stinging nettles grow around
the world but they're much more than
just weeds nettle tea is good against
bloating nettles promote healthy blood
as they have a lot of iron and a lot of
vitamins they're rich in vitamin C and a
and cooked they taste like spinach
besides nettles and veal Merrick needs
fresh asparagus for this dish as with
almost all his produce he gets it from
local farmers during the season which
lasts till late June German farmers
mostly harvest white asparagus but some
have other preferences bog for me real
asparagus is green which is still very
very popular in most of Europe even
though white asparagus is much more
popular in Germany it's just a lovely
tender vegetable in early spring from
hand to mouth almost in the kitchen
Marek first washes the nettles
thoroughly in warm water
flower for the pasta dough salt and eggs
they're all blended together with the
nettles into a dough then chef Marc
needs the dough by hand adding oil and
he lets it sit for an hour in the
refrigerator but there's always room for
experimentation if I can do nettle pasta
like this but I can also add beetroot of
different herbs and then I have a real
variety something you can't go out and
buy he adds butter and sugar to the
boiling water for the asparagus to give
it a sweet note and there's another
important detail the end pieces are
woody we don't want that but there's
also another reason this way the
asparagus is all the same length will
now cut them off like this
another tip don't throw away the end
pieces you can use them to make cream of
asparagus soup he bundles the asparagus
stalks into equal portions and then
boils them for six to eight minutes
it's time to take the dough out of the
refrigerator this should be sliced like
bread and then rolled out very thinly
with a pasta machine or a rolling pin
dust with flour and cut into strips then
boil in hot water pepper and salt the
veal and then fry on both sides in
butter then place it in the oven I
always put the meat in the oven between
100 and 110 degrees Celsius so that the
meat stays juicy I don't want the meat
to get tough or dry for the herb jacket
there's parsley and rosemary first Marik
fries the veal filet in time and bastes
it several times with hot butter then he
turns over the meat in the other herbs
the veal filet in an herb jacket with
asparagus stems and nettle pasta is now
ready and to go with it white wine and
of course this view of Lake Constance